what a way to kick off the new year the
Epstein court documents are set to be
released very soon they were supposed to
come out today I don't know what's going
on with it the latest reporting from the
your times that they will come out
shortly and numerous reports State Bill
Clinton is expected to be on the list
now Aaron Rogers says Jimmy Kimmel's
probably on the list Jimmy Kimmel got
really mad started uh going after Aaron
Rogers saying I have never met that guy
I'm not on any lists but it's not the
list it's not Client List it's a list of
names related to a c a defamation court
case so the name May Donald Trump could
be in the court documents these
documents are just part of a defamation
suit where there's a bunch of people who
may be in the documents let's say
someone said shortly after I left Donald
Trump's party I you know got into a car
and looked on my phone and saw that
someone had said nasty words about me
well that's a name that could appear in
these court papers so don't get your
hopes up about several hundred people
who are going to appear on this list but
we are expected to learn the the names
of several Associates of Jeffrey Epstein
so it is still a pretty big story